on a commencé là on a attendu que ça
ouais on est là à peu près donc la
sortie c'est tout différent par rapport
à l'année dernière le labyrinthe des ou
qu'ils aient des illusions d'optique
celui des tracteurs ou encore des
légumes sont accessibles à partir de 3
ans dès le mois de juin de nouveaux
labyrinthes viendront s'ajouter à cette
liste
donc ces différents labyrinthes donc
point s'en sont sont au nombre de quatre
c'est donc des petits labyrinthes deux
petits pour les enfants et 2 qui sont un
peu plus grands qu'ils ne peuvent pas
faire seul tout au long de leur parcours
les visiteurs doivent résoudre de
petites énigmes
je m'attendais pas ce qui est des
petites des petits panneaux avec des
questions pour les enfants donc à
l'entrée nous donne une petite feuille
pour répondre à des questions donc ça
pimente le parcours de plein de types
pause ludique c'est très chouette des
labyrinthes qui ne sont pas si simples
au début fin j'ai vu qu'il ya une
technique en fait faut toujours posé sa
main droite sur les sur les yeux et on
arrivera toujours à la sortie du coup
j'ai essayé mais ça m'a ramené un
cul-de-sac en sont un autre ça marche
pas du tout le réconfort après l'effort
les visiteurs peuvent faire une pause
gourmande
après les labyrinthes alors le point des
gourmands donc c'est plusieurs petites
choses qu'on va vendre ici en même temps
que labyrinthes du coup donc on a les
glaces quand il fait beau et chaud sinon
on a donc comme vous le voyez derrière
moi donc plutôt des petites gourmandises
chaude donc des beignets des madeleines
dépeinte érables des brioches perdu à
partir du 7 juillet les labyrinthes
seront ouverts tous les jours des
nocturnes avec des soirées barbecues
seront organisés sur réservation